president biden of course no stranger to
the state of nevada he campaigned across
the silver state the past couple of
years
during his most recent bid for the white
house and orco mana spoke
one-on-one with the president on the
campaign trail a few times
he joins us live now with more on their
conversations orco
well brian i had the opportunity to
interview president joe biden
three times last year as he made
different campaign stocks in las vegas
and in each of those interviews he spoke
about the america he
wanted to build if he was elected now
that time has come
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
joe biden is officially the 46th
president of the united states a big
theme of his inauguration day speech
wednesday was unity a message he shared
with me even back in may during the
democratic primaries
i think we're having to have a very
united party
and my message to all and what they're
finding out now that
the nomination process is de facto over
they're finding out the positions i had
an awful lot of things
were not accurately characterized and uh
and they're feeling more comfortable
with it but i'm listening
i'm here i need them and i hope they all
will join us and now president
biden is hoping supporters of donald
trump will join him including republican
lawmakers
of course one of the biggest challenges
requiring collaboration
is how to handle the covet 19 pandemic
and its devastating effect on the
economy
in my interview with him in october
president biden pledged to provide
more federal support there's money there
to make sure we should be
providing extended unemployment benefits
we should be making sure those small
businesses are going out of business
have the ability to stay open have the
ability to sanitize have the
ability to test and trace have the
ability to bring in customers
with some confidence president biden has
also set an ambitious goal he has
promised to get 100 million doses of the
covet 19 vaccine into the arms of
americans
during his first 100 days in office
now president biden has several other
major tasks ahead of him as well but as
he told me in our interviews
he's ready to get to work brian orko
before you go
from your experience with him and then
from listening in on the speech
what did you make of the tone president
biden was trying to set today
well like i mentioned president biden's
goal is to move forward together and in
my interviews with him he was very clear
about bringing everyone to the table
across the whole political spectrum
and that is the message we saw today the
question now
is whether or not we will actually see
true bipartisan
bipartisanship in washington back to you
all right orco thank you for that denise